[Music]
foreign
first of all happy birthday thank you at
the new end
thank you for inviting me and y'all this
is very exciting
fully back so we are here at disneyland
patricia's birthday
fully backed vaccination
okay we are shooting our first
ever frenemies vlog number one if you
guys like it
more to come maybe i get so nervous
filming in public people watching us
oh but i have no shame i know i'm so
weird i just feel like people are like
nobody in my head everyone's like why
are they filming who do they think they
are
like that's like oh well we have two
security guards
just because i mean we are kind of a big
deal
so at any rate um we are going to be
doing a food vlog
today they say calories don't count at
disneyland and today we're here to prove
that wrong
yeah i was just here to eat and you're
like i want to eat like you
yeah i'm sorry that came off wrong but i
was like well because i'm on a diet and
stuff and i've been like
really tight today so it's like today's
the ultimate cheat day
i'm going to eat everything trisha eats
and it's your birthday
let's go right they have birthday
churros here now that's like a new thing
yeah like a birthday cake oh yeah i want
to eat like everything fried
my birthday yes so every time
we eat food we're gonna film it and
we're gonna do
a food journey
and people are asking it for in line so
embarrassing and that's it that's the
vlog
that's the vlog so join us on a magical
adventure of uh
gluttony and uh what else
happiness really
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
so you want to introduce we're at the
dole whip we're by the tiki room this is
my favorite
i always come here first it starts the
day off right
oh
this is the magic the magic kingdom has
lost a little bit of magic well it's
like um
we got a special collector's cup but i
have to put the ice cream
and the crackers well you can just have
that if you
the tv room
you're the only one who doesn't eat this
with me so i'm planning to tell you
super
well thank god because i've been to
rockwood everyone just stopped for me
they were trying to to eat skinny i
think so i think that's how most people
eat they wait for their meals
have you lived like that i gotta tell
you i've had this before
it tastes really good today must be the
culvert or something but
it's better it's also like a birthday
and like
it's excitement really nice texture kilo
you want to give it a try
[Laughter]
i love it people aren't a fan but i
thought this is a staple i didn't mean
[Music]
maybe i don't know we have a lot of
rides to go on so i don't want to get
sick
will you be mad if i throw the cup out
because i don't want i don't know how am
i going to go what if you want to knock
your giveaway for people
if you want the cup comment below but i
don't want
the next fan that says hi i'll see you
like here's my cup this has been used
you can call me
oh my god this is good that's the way to
start it
it's frozen yogurt light refreshing yeah
yeah we walked all the way to indiana
jones and right as we got there
they're like it's close i was like do
you know how much we pay for this vip
experience
you get on that track you get out of
your [ __ ] wrench and you start
clunking at that like minecraft space
you're actually not a diva at all i
thought you might be like
i don't know why but not a bad way just
in a very like oh
you know i hate that but i was gonna be
really moody at disney or just in
general before you met me
more like not moody but no at disney's
particularly that maybe like oh
you know like i mean like waiting cause
people who are used to vip tours you
know they might be like oh we don't want
to stand here
oh stop it okay i don't know i thought
you know some people
and not because of anything else other
than your parents your stress you know
what i mean like
that well so but you're saying i'm
humble you're saying i'm a humble normal
guy you're a humble king
thank you you're all i'm a queen and
king right here though yeah
yeah it doesn't matter that there's a
security guard next to me when i feed
the same as everybody i like it though
it makes me feel actually safe
because in general not even being on the
internet i always think people are
trying to kill me
just in general like i think people want
to murder me i'm very scared of
strangers i don't know if that's like a
thing you need i'm scared too
because it's funny i grew up in israel
where you actually
oh my god
it's not really a rational fear but i
think my dad raised me that way like
you're super friendly about locking the
doors
my parents were really hysterical about
strangers um my background is not like
that i
am like i remember one time me and my
brother were in a band
sitting with my mom in a band while my
dad was inside doing something in a
store
yeah and some guy walked by and she said
oh my god he tried to open the door
kidnap you guys
and to this day i go i don't think that
happened
she was so hysterical that this guy
tried to open the door and kidnap us
so i feel like she i feel like she
[ __ ] me up oh [ __ ] that's why i need
therapy before i have kisses i'll do
that to my kids i'll be like
they want to kill us like i always just
assume that
i also love that you're talking about
that at the tiki room did you hear what
the speaker was saying
no what does it say it was just saying
like to like love everybody and like
whatever
you're like and they're gonna come [ __ ]
nevermind
[Music]
yeah and she's like apparently that's
like she goes we can't talk about it
just watch the shane dawson series on it
she was like legitimately no no no no
matterhorn you got people
yeah we get kicked out we're talking
about it
someone died on the on the boat on the
matterhorn
the mast fell on people so where did i
[Music]
[Music]
this is gonna be a four-hour long
mukbang of us eating
i think we'll go watch it it's just us
eating i'm having fun
but we were supposed to stop okay now
all right ready
let's do pirates okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
because it's telling us
[Music]
all right we survived
you don't eat the dog i don't like hot
dogs what yeah
that's right you spit it out while we
did the show yeah i don't even know what
like five minutes so you just want deep
fried corn right now
yeah basically i just like the outer
part interesting so here we're doing a
corn dog reveal
oh can you put the bite back on cake
cheers but you like these you eat these
on your own without me
mm-hmm
oh yeah all this skinny legends are
drinking diet coke
i will i like that product you know what
trump
what trump has the best quote this one
i'll give to him he said
i have never seen a skinny person
drinking diet coke
he tweeted that he's like you know what
no and he looking you're firing back
are you just skinny i don't think
getting pregnant
okay so there you go jump proven wrong
longer than [ __ ]
it's weird though because look moses
drinks the sugar one right
he always does he didn't drink so much
sugar right so
i don't know this is so good we haven't
even bite in the dog
really yeah i hate it i love i love corn
okay i nipped my nail i was grating
cheese
and i grinded my thumb doing what oh
brightening cheese but like
it doesn't hurt except you don't like
them i was grinding farmers i made
buttered pasta
for you i mean in honor of you
it was for elo i did butter
stop telling me what we like i hate it
did you like it
i did like it you ate the barbecue
cheese yes he bought it because of you
i was i was supposed to make you
buttered noodles for your birthday
but i didn't have time so i made it for
you honestly that would have been really
exciting i would have been really happy
i just i forgot about it i had the
parmesan cheese in the fridge
so i made it for ela and i [ __ ] my
thumb up
what are you gonna do about the top is
like a little cornbread there that's not
it's just bread
this is so good this is the breading on
this is better than everything
any condiments no i don't like sauces
no sauce no exception
no right always awesome no soft no
[Music]
so um this is our second food item today
it's not that much though right like we
haven't been i've been kind of impressed
with
trisha because i feel like i would be
stopping for more food well
they haven't been open until noon
because we gotta get a birthday churro i
always get popcorn
i love the candy apples there's like a
store right there that has nanny apples
so then so churros next yeah
birthday charles that it's new here i
love that mm-hmm
what do you rate it the corn dog
am i writing it against other corn dogs
it's all foods
no i'm tired it's like an 8 out of 10.
how could you bring it up
how could you rate it when you don't
even use the hot dog
but you see what i'm saying it's kind of
a problem with your rating
how can it be a perfect score if you're
not eating half of it it just slid off
look at that
that's so good i would eat that
what do i want it
you see that tip bite moses is looking
disgusted by me
are you disgusted that it's her dog or
the tip i didn't do anything to him
yeah i just watched her more like it
looks like a dog's tip yeah
i like that that's a great tip
does it go without the fried mm-hmm
without the batter
really damnation baby
it's a sports day so can you not have a
cheat day tomorrow this is your friday
yeah i'll probably skip tomorrow
but i was good yesterday in preparation
as well
every morning i wake up and this is the
day i'm going to start keto i'm going to
lose a bunch of weight and shock
everybody
but it never happened at night before i
go to bed
i'm the most i'm the strongest most
powerful person i can do anything and
then you stuffed yourself the day before
and so then you're like i'm so sick with
myself that's like i stopped myself like
i'm so disgusting i'm not eating
tomorrow
for always at night before bed right and
then rolls around you're like man i'm
getting really hungry
i'm hungry because i can skip breakfast
but then noon
in my head i visualize myself like
dropping 80 pounds everything whoa
she did it like she's so skinny you can
do it
no i really can't i've tried so many
times i really have i really do
sabotage myself i'll lose like 10 pounds
and then i'm like okay time to gain it
right
that's the hardest i always do that
it's hard to push past that part where
you're like i lost it now you got to
reward myself for one day
and then one day turns into a month and
you're just as bad as you were and then
you're like [ __ ] it yeah i'm just batter
i didn't get better every day
i both wait though yeah you have and my
birthing ways to shut you was you're
skinny
i know i was like oh my god i've never
heard that but you are you are sitting
here in front of me i think like
you said like i'm skinny again you don't
flatter yourself on camera
that's true okay well we'll check back
in when the trolls are here
okay all right okay birthday cheryl this
is new edge's name
hero game what's new about it just the
birthday sprinkles
just the i don't know the blue
oh very dandy
i'm textured yeah in green you like the
sand
do you like any sand yeah i like the
texture of a charm
oh you brought the dip i brought it
maybe it doesn't give it a dip let's see
what it's like
it seems like a lot we'll try the dip
it's your birthday i'll hold it down
okay thank you i don't know what this is
no we're literally here with a guide
i didn't double dip this at the end well
i'm not gonna oh should i use it too you
have to try it if i try it
oh [ __ ] you got a little marshmallow on
yourself
i got it so can i can i dip with it
it is can i dip with this gum
why do you like that what do you do
are you not impressed maybe a regular
one would have been better
who's standing right yeah i don't like
my fingers
what we've been all over the disney
rides we think it's okay
yeah they have like yeah that's fine i'm
licking my fingers we're vaccinated
very sandy i'm like warm and gooey
inside
that's my review
is this why i got money is this in place
of monday's episode
no no no inaudible
i gotta get put here in front of the
castle before we leave this area
okay cheers right i'm popcorn
yeah yeah they're done
i'm game i'm super standing all right i
don't know why candy
you don't know what i mean by that it's
like super great it's like putting sand
in your mouth with the sugar
sugar the texture it's like eating
the lipstick
no don't we have seen
keeping people at bay
[Music]
would moses be considered a friend of
the show
i don't know what goes into the front of
the show
oh i use it very loosely though yeah i
was gonna say you kind of say everyone's
friend of the show
yeah if i know them they're friends i
think nobody's running the show
really no i don't what about hilo
he's more than that though he's your
fiance and my brother-in-law
that's a big yeah there's a lot going on
there
do you think dan is friend of the show
right here on the bench like do a little
homeless action at disney
d5 remember what people used to play
you're flanking wait what would that
mean face down and you're like straight
on
and you flank on a trash can that was
birthday
am i done or do i stay i think you're
good
i'm more embarrassed and i'm not even
doing it i'm gonna get up you let me
know if you want any more plans
he
okay
[Music]
[Music]
full
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i have to say though there's really
nothing cinderelly about eating buttered
popcorn
it's just really like don't go away it's
just like the magix
[Music]
this is my favorite i've ever done
really
you know you can't do that i love
popcorn
i didn't eat the corn dog
hot dog i
[Music]
oh
popcorn what do you say about it it's
popcorn i'm gonna give it out
eight that's four oh you got an eight
what are you
[Music]
you guys are doing it is
[Music]
[Music]
they don't lift it you want me to put in
your mouth
cleanliness
out of them here eat more
think about it be serious about it
[Music]
yeah right because it's warm
[Music]
how much sodium
[Music]
70 milligrams probably something like
that actually
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
you're welcome to the ball
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right orgy review for your review
the reviews are in they're good yeah 10
stars
it's got a magnet i'm so sweaty and i
got a magnet on mine too
porky all right oh my hands
if we touched it that's the thing
this reminds me of we're like little
rascals i got a pickle i got a pickle
i got a pickle hey inappropriate joke
after the touch tip
no
yeah let's just see
i'm gonna tell you
it's too there's too much soft tissue
it's too big of a pickle like a small
pickle
one that doesn't big
pickles are too uncomfortable i like a
small thing
fits perfectly i'm not a size queen
i definitely need it the skin is like
tight and chewy
i'm not into it either i hate everything
about pickles
what's the reveal
three all right one minute what's up
after that reveal
i have dinner three pickles
okay all right pretzel okay did you dip
it in the cheese or not oh yeah
right mickey mouse face we love it okay
that's cute
that's really cute i'm gonna take one no
no we rip it apart like a wishbone oh
okay
so you'll get the bigger piece right
here okay i win
yeah really for sure oh my god i was
getting competitive for a minute
no but i think the cheese is the focus
the cheetah
not it no food how do you think
that's not it is it um
disney's been sitting on this since
before the friend that's right
they finally gave it to us
[Music]
honestly
that's your sale you want this really
different
the difference with them no i'm staying
at it you know what's [ __ ] up
i'm still eating well we're eating
dinner like an hour
[Music]
is not good the cheese is not good we
tried it no
they're not very tasty no all right
should we try these turkeys
i'm just i'm such a disaster are we
going to be no it's not bad
it's like we're all eating dinner in an
hour
it's a trigger in our family like if you
tell someone like we're about to eat
soon it's like well i'm gonna eat them
too
i'm literally over here eating this okay
but you have an evil day
and like honestly we're sure yeah you
[Music]
[Music]
oh it is dripping in grease i was saying
you think these poor turkeys get a break
in between thanksgiving but business oh
this is like a lot okay
ready it smells like bacon oh can you
eat bacon
well it's not
you can use it as a weapon you can eat
it i don't know if i like it
really i was kind of playing it up
honestly
but do you love it i don't love it i
don't want this red meat it's very gamey
i feel like i'm eating a beer moja's
going at it with his hands
i love it it's so good well i need i
only have one
hand no no oh
no i can't even do it
oh
yeah we waited a long time for it too it
took off so that was a negative like
100 out of 100 negative experience
just took away from our experiences
we could have been on right at the
resistance again
the good thing is we got smart weather
yeah it's the only place that doesn't
have lasagna in that stand so that was
good
a lot of hate for dasani here today
well you know all together that was 160
for the legs and the pretzels
[Music]
i like how you do it for the turkey
nobody wants it
it's just so chewy yeah you know what
i'm trying this one
okay we're on the bus we weren't let's
be honest
this needs to we're just satisfied we're
on the bus eating domino's
well just satisfied with the dinner
options we had an alfredo dining
or el fresco dining it was trash what
was that place i'll put them on blast
it was called uh part day circle
park day circle we're getting diamond
hose
dominoes any excuse for nominals but if
we if we get home successfully if we
drop you guys off safe and sound
that means dominoes will repeat
themselves so we can order it more on
the show
i really hope nothing bad happens
because i really want to dispel the
curse
okay don't put it out there you just put
it out there
not only good things come from this
anyway pizza's great
best meal of the day easily that's sad
but it's true
it's sad but it's true and it's so good
disneyland was good well i think i think
of all the things we ate today this is
my favorite
i'm still playing right i mean we've
gotta be there it was not disney's fault
what did what do you
like better today what would you have
got to eat again besides it this is not
one
yeah nothing honestly i could have just
stayed home and eating pizza all day me
too we could have saved a lot of money
yeah we could have just not even talked
my stomach can't take anymore those
noodles were disgusting
the turkey leg was gross like my stomach
hurt so bad
you know it started strong with the duel
with what they talked
the churro was good the corn dog was
good yeah it was all downhill
the lid the legs rough you didn't even
want them you're like i don't want
inside
i crush them what an adventure first
vlog
i think that's great i don't care what
people think
well happy birthday
see you guys on uh mondays tuesday
oh yeah bye bye
[Music]